Ray uh very uh difficult tournament for
you it didn't start off well with that
game against uh Sam you were winning in
that one unfortunately you weren't able
to convert but finally you're breaking
the ice this Rook takes F7 tell us the
story of that
move uh yeah I guess Rook F7 was the
plan when I went for F5 F5 was very
committal I think obviously I could have
played something like Rook A1 and I
thought I'm just better but F5 is super
direct so it could be very good or could
actually even like give away everything
I could be worse immediately probably it
was just a force draw but um yeah so
like F5 Rook E5 FG HD Bishop D4 and then
in this position he has like uh five or
six options so for example Rook E6 uh
was an option so that I don't have Rook
F7 ideas because now he guards G6 and
then I had been planning Knight F5
uh after Rook e
six and then the point is if he takes
take um he can even play Rook F6
immediately okay Play Bishop F6 has
Queen B6 but yeah have Queen H5 and
what's really yeah what's really funny
is Queen H5 I'm not actually threatening
the
bishop but he actually also can't move
so my threat is something like Rook F4
because his Rook is pinned to the mate
threat on h8 and he actually just can't
stop it he can include C5 Bishop E5 but
I don't think it changes anything and
this is a very funny um kind of trap but
yeah after uh Rook E6 Knight F5 there
was Bishop G5 um which wasn't clear so I
mean probably F5 wasn't the the best
objectively but it was just so tempting
so Rook E8 was another option and then
this Rook sacrifice seemed kind of
forced and it was hard for me to
evaluate from AAR excuse me
sorry about that um but I thought I
should always have at least a draw so it
was still kind of safe and here yeah I
mean there's King E6 or King E7 it's
funny like there there's actually
differences but he went King E7 which
allowed Bishop C5 and I took on G6 which
could have just transposed and I thought
he had to go King D7 and I couldn't find
a I couldn't find anything better than a
draw I was looking for some way to like
maybe pick up the bishop on H4 and just
have uh a strong position but I didn't
actually see a clear away so there were
like tons of checks so many different
options but um yeah I thought that was a
draw with Bishop E6 I had seen uh
basically everything that happened in
the game up to 94 from afar um and 94 is
obviously I don't know if it's the only
move but it's really really nice yes um
with the point that if he takes I have
Rook F5 check giving up my Rook as well
and then Bishop takes F5 Queen C3 uh
I'll give m a few moves yeah Queen E5 B3
and queen A5 M yeah very nice a lot of
beautiful geometry in uh this game Ray
uh congratulations an important victory
for you how do you assess your game so
far sure the result hasn't been the best
but you did get some good positions how
do you assess how do you feel about your
chest so
far yeah I mean I wasn't I haven't been
playing very well but I did have some
good positions like you said I mean the
first game I was completely winning
against I mean completely is a little
bit of an overstatement in terms of
there wasn't like a direct win but just
the position was pretty overwhelming uh
against Sean and there was literally no
way I could lose that one and uh after I
made a mistake and he got back in the
game I ended up just like making a crazy
decision not to force a draw instead of
playing a position where I can only be
worse so I somehow ended up losing that
one and uh yeah then I uh lost another
one uh so I don't know my play has been
I mean I lost to Misha he played a great
game I have to say I did have a chance
to get an advantage at one for one move
but it was extremely complicated um so I
don't know I'm feeling a little bit
better than the first few days trying to
play a a little bit better as well um I
probably could have scored some more
points with the positions I had but just
have to accept uh what's happened still
a lot of rounds to go we'll let you go
get ready for the next one and we'll see
you
tomorrow than uh thank you Ray indeed